leute was soll ich sagen wir haben im
heutigen video wirklich eine ganz
besondere person wir haben einen der
klügsten menschen bzw einen der menschen
mit den klügsten entscheidungen in
seinem leben gefunden
ihr habt so viel ferngesehen leute ich
muss dazu in vorneweg nicht viele worte
verlieren es ist der junge mit den
dümmsten tattoo der welt es in deutscher
und wir schauen jetzt rein
wir besuchen an die in seiner wohnung in
berlin
hier präsentiert er uns seinen tatort
raum ein 18 zentimeter großes
mittelfinger meisterwerk das ist ja
wirklich zu nahes alter weg wie kommt
man in seinem leben an dem punkt an dass
man sich einen mittelfinger auf dem auch
noch was da steht auch noch etwas drauf
bist du nicht auf seiner so aus wie
kommt man an diesem punkt ich bin sehr
gespannt
der 22 jährige vor vier jahren wie kann
es anders sein es oft nicht etwa beim
profi nein ein kumpel stach zu ich lasse
mich einfach mit screenshot hier leute
okay gibt vergeblich dieses feature sagt
eigentlich schon alles
schaut euch das an da ist schon alles
gesagt wisst ihr wisst ihr nämlich das
erinnert an das erinnert mich an dave
ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich da komme ich
von mir da macht jetzt auch seit einiger
zeit youtube seit einigen monaten ist
auch gut dabei an diese person muss ich
weil diese video denken weil nur dave
kenne ich der sowas machen würde dave
hat sich auch selbst an tätowiert hat
sie eine steckdose tätowiert hat sich
ein stuhl selbst tätowiert war der
einzige mensch den ich in diese richtung
irgendwie was zutrauen würde aber der
hier ist ja noch krasser als dave sogar
zugesagt so ja ein bisschen dazu zu
gehören so mache ich mich vielleicht ein
bisschen finger so generell den anderen
zu sagen hier bin ich ich höre erst
wirklich der größte aller zeiten ich
will auch gar nicht so eine auf den
machen soll wie dumm von ihm für mich
überhaupt nicht ich fühle es dass man
sich soll ich mir jetzt an denn
schlechtes vorbild ich fühle es schon
muss ich ganz ehrlich gestehen sich
gelegentlich mit ein paar guten freunden
einfach mal komplett aus dem leben zu
scheiden das für dich da mache ich doch
nichts vor das ist so und ich will auch
gar nicht an dieser stelle sagen was ich
alles schon scheiße gebaut habe als ich
einem t hatte
insofern auf dieser web für die aktion
schon ein bisschen ja ich war jung und
brauchte was noch blöder jungen stellten
sich an die und seinem kumpel bei der
wahl der vorlage an die röhre mal eben
gegoogelt und fanden das hier also man
muss wirklich schon einen speziellen
grad an betrunken sein erreichen glaube
ich damit man das macht weil einerseits
muss er natürlich erstmal überzeugt
wären dass er das macht andererseits
muss der kumpel aber auch noch seine
hand so weit im griff an dass er das
noch machen kann
das wahlalter nicht ganz ehrlich ich
würde also soweit ich muss ich wirklich
sagen krass krass verkackt mit diesem
tabu
aber ich würde gerne mit ihm entgehen
ich würde gern mal dabei sein an abenden
wo der pegel so hoch ist dass sowas hier
passieren kann eigentlich dienstnehmer
gewesen und das habe ich mir bewusst
gemacht was hat mich nicht so toll ist
vielleicht hätten wir nicht so viel
trinken sondern wir es vielleicht
halbwegs gut geworden
[Musik]
es sollte eigentlich sagen 54
aber was ist er für ein ehrenmann alter
ich kann noch nicht so ganz einordnen
wie er sie zu dem tattoo besteht also
einerseits denke dass ich bestimmte
haarverlust ich aber andererseits denke
dass ich natürlich auch um ein grad
wasser wieder getan so aber abhängig
davon wie sehr er ein stabiler deutsches
auf bruder ist könnte es eigentlich auch
schon in richtung ja ich bin ich
trotzdem mehr lustig als schlimmen gehen
ja bei solchen freunden braucht man
keine feinde mehr
an die neun frauen des kreis denn so ein
neuer kumpel nick von der sofort auch
okay okay das ist wiederum jetzt mal ein
anderer tourist also wenn es tatsächlich
so sein sollte dass er sich jetzt wegen
der aktion von seinem alten
freundeskreis des distanzierter dann
heißt das ja auf ihres leaders er hätte
doch mehr schlimm als lustig findet wenn
er deswegen sich von seinen freunden los
sagt ich finde ich bin ein bisschen
sprachlos ich fühle wie gesagt ich hatte
ihn schon meinte die diesen mut diesen
modus dass man so einen winter hat man
irgendwie scheiße baut so dass für ich
bin ich vollkommen dabei ja bla bla bla
sollte man nicht machen und erwachsenen
verhalten aber bei ihm ist es ja schon
mal wirklich ernst wirklich
drinnen bei wels wurde von securitys
angewiesen sein t shirt wieder
anzuziehen
also ok sorry aber also ich dass er
jetzt nicht so gerne im freibad
rumturnen was ich mir das bisschen
peinlich das kann ich verstehen aber
warum sollten ihn festival securities
bitten das t shirt anzuziehen so was
passieren kann sich irgendeiner an dem
mittelfinger stoßen oder wie es kann man
kann man sich einem tattoo schneiden
also das einzige was mir vorstellen kann
ist das vielleicht vor der bühne oder
auf dem festival so aufnahmen gemacht
werden und die das nicht in ihrem image
film haben wollen oder irgendwas haben
an sich ist doch eigentlich lustig der
jeder von euch ja schon auf dem fest wer
weiß was da abgeht und das ist einfach
eine riesige gesetzlose haufen ist da
ist so etwas geil hier wird das feiern
also das bild wirklich nicht ganz so
auch mit freunden baden gehen ist für
den 22 jährigen extrem als ob das okay
das ist wirklich krass also sorry na
also wenn ich jetzt ich hoffe ich hab
jetzt habe ich die falsche geschlagen
als ich gerade meinte ehemann und dass
ich so diesen modus so ein bisschen
zumindest nachvollziehen kann der sollte
jetzt auch nicht zu enthusiastisch
wirken leuten also jetzt sehen wir ja
offensichtlich dass er damit auch ein
bisschen kämpft sondern muss man auch
sich da ein bisschen mehr zurückhalten
hat dafür verständnis
ja und dann dieses gefühl täuscht nicht
die reaktionen auf das mittelfinger tat
um holte wir mit dem 22 jährigen ein
spaßbad gehen
ich hab' ich habe mich an leute ich habe
überhaupt keinen spaß wenn ich dieses
video sei kein spaß 0
mehr aber im ernst versuchen wir mal
eine andere perspektive auf die sache
leute was wäre wenn seine freunde ihn so
ein bisschen genötigt haben und
ausgenutzt haben dass er vielleicht der
betrunkene war zu diesem zeitpunkt das
wäre natürlich eine riesen hus aktion
von seinen freunden so was geht gar
nicht unter freunden passt man natürlich
aufeinander auf auch wenn man feiern ist
auch immer natürlich dreht und passt
auch folgen am meisten auf die leute auf
die attacken also dass wenn das so ist
geht das gar nicht
könnt ihr übrigens auch könnte fast
körperverletzung sein oder
also ich mir das vorstelle ich bin kein
anwalt so ich habe bisschen auch
interesse mich mit gesetzen so
auseinander zu setzen wenn er nicht bei
klaren kopf ist der andere der
integriert aber bei klaren kopf ist in
dem moment und man irgendwie davon
ausgehen muss dass er in nüchternem
zustand dass niemals gemacht hätte ist
das dann ist es dann schon eine
körperverletzung also ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass in die richtung geht
weiter ein bisschen aber was hat man
erwartet was die leute ihm schon mal
sagen dieser mittel dieses mittelfinger
tattoo das ist nicht einfach negativ zu
beurteilen da als eine differenzierte
betrachtung notwendig das hat auch seine
positiven seiten
nein selbstständig sagt jeder der das
konsulat stinkefinger stimmte auch an
die mittlerweile gewaltig ein charakter
soll das teil endlich verwerten und er
wird heute in unserem team
schadensbegrenzung betreiben
daniel krause und deutsch verstehe ich
also er hat jetzt die mission dass er
das datum natürlich irgendwie ein
bisschen abdecken will macht jetzt ein
cover up also wahrscheinlich ein
größeres tattoo was da oben drüber kommt
was du bist in die formen von dem alten
tattoo mit einbaut dass man nicht auf
den ersten blick sieht was da
ursprünglich mal drauf war so nice
baxter
oberkörper frei rumlaufen ist für andy
kaum noch drin drei fragezeichen
außer zu hause im schwimmbad vor fremden
und ab aber es hat ja auch irgendwas
lustiges sollte also ich ganz ehrlich
ich glaube wenn ich in seiner rolle wäre
würde ich natürlich irgendwie mich dafür
schämen so normal als normales und
sicher verstehen aber ich glaube der
beste umgang mit solchen sachen ist ja
auch einfach vielleicht nicht allzu
ernst zu nehmen auch wenn es einem
persönlichen schreiben man dass man mit
einer prise humor nimmt ist es
wahrscheinlich die beste art und weise
damit umzugehen so guckt euch jetzt in
den total charmant tolle frisur und dann
nimmt ihn mit nach hause
man kennt das man kennt das vergucken in
der diskothek total charmant und tolle
frisur das sind die hauptfaktoren die
dafür sorgen dass leute aus einem
nachtclub the way was ist ein nachtclub
so ich war seit märz in keinem mehr wir
sollten ist das sind die hauptfaktoren
dafür dass zwei leute nicht alleine nach
hause gehen man muss schon mal gemacht
man muss wirklich charmant sein aber
frisur frisur ist das a und o beim club
statt einem stinkefinger und ziert nun
ein wassermann die brust des 22-jährigen
ein paar details fehlen noch planung
muss in einer zweiten session noch mal
an
naja ok gut aber ich weiß ich weiß nicht
ob das das cover up auch so krass fühle
ehrlich gesagt heißt nicht dass triggert
irgendwie so meine aus leute kennt ihr
das wenn ihr so den ticker dass alles in
ordnung sein muss es muss bei mir müsste
das perfekt in der mitte sein perfekte
metrisch aber gut wenn wir am ende mal
ehrlich mit uns sind ist das schon eine
massive verbesserung das hier meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren war ein
erziehungs video von ihrem lieblings
youtuber escape darüber dass man im
leben gerne einmal feiern gehen darf
auch über die stränge schlagen darf aber
immer diese neigen schritt bevor ab die
klippe kommt sofort der abhang kommt wo
man tief hält diesen schritt darf man
nicht gehen
ok erklärte vorgeschlagen das video ab
abonniert hier um einen kanal ich bin
der star aus